[Música]
soñar soñar
hermoso soñar para nosotros tener sueños
cosas de chicos chicos recuerdo teniendo
89 años
más de uno seguramente me va a entender
tenía una pelotita de goma una púlpito
zapatillas flechas un arco gigante en el
paredón del vecino
y empatía valores y oraciones jugando y
pateando y soñando hasta el crack de
independiente
ricardo bueno
yo lo veía cómo saltaba el señor ser
como él como cabeceaba como decía está
esos pases milimétricos
el compañero es en mis sueños
después creciendo
entra en la secundaria
ya era ver que hacía por el futuro
consiguiendo el futuro y bueno estoy acá
soy técnico electrónico tengo que
estudiar para ser técnico electrónico y
así me tengo que recibir cuando salte de
la secundaria el día que salga de la
secundaria voy a empezar a estudiar lo
que yo quiero realmente
terminé la secundaria
empiezan a escuchar a los adultos que
estaban al lado mío que me decían
el día que tenga plata ahí voy a empezar
a sentir lo que es vivir
el día en cambio de gobierno ahí vamos a
empezar a sentirnos como bailes
el día que me separé de tu padre
voy a empezar a ver lo que voy a hacer
de mi vida
el día que el día que hizo la misma yo
el día que entré para ser ingeniero
electrónico ahí voy a empezar a sentir
ese día llegó
2 de marzo de 1982
presente en la universidad tecnológica
nacional
córdoba y lateral
paredes enormes esas ventanas grandes
me dije el día que es el ingeniero
electrónico
ahí me las entiende desarrolla
dos meses después dos meses después
2 de mayo de 1982
estaba en una trinchera cayeron 21
bombas de 500 kilos
de malvinas
una trinchera estaba mojado con frío
sino el barro
la comida nos llegaba
teníamos miedo las bombas se empezaron a
explotar desde ese primero de mayo al 14
de junio fueron explotando a lo largo de
todos los días todo el día en distintos
lugares de la isla
empezamos a ver la muerte
empezamos a ver el miedo
la mutilación
en frío
ya no había futuro
futuro de aquí y ahora
no sé qué voy a comer mañana que como
hoy
como salgo de ésta hoy como sobrevivo
está
mojados
no había nada
darme cuenta
lo que daría en mi compañero
el que estaba la trinchera
que estaba al lado mío
los ojos
me abrazaba después nos dábamos calor y
aliento
habíamos salido de acá de la tablada del
regimiento 3 de infantería
la compañía del regimiento de infantería
tenía un líder un líder de eso qué
vale la pena llevarlo a todos lados era
un sargento en el ejército manuel ángel
villegas tenía cuatro años más que yo un
tipo que te miraba los ojos entendía con
la trama que te retaba que éste
levantaba el peso que te indicaba lo que
tenía que hacer para sobrevivir
no había diferencia sociedad
el hijo del empresario dijo el cartonero
estamos en la misma situación si había
un pedazo de pan lo compartíamos ya no
había futuro
aprendimos a agradecer
agradecerle a dios algunos llamaban al
lado de benicio no creo en nada no
importaba no había religión a viable
teníamos esa fe
sólo podrá empezar que ver ese calor
séptima el brillo objetiva el miedo se
lleva al hambre estamos juntos nos
abrazábamos sabíamos lo que
necesitábamos nosotros
el 13 de junio entramos en combate
la compañía del regimiento 3 baja del
monte también casco colocado fusil en
mano municiones en todos los bolsillos y
vamos bajando lo más rápido posible muy
de noche muy de noche que los ingleses
no detecten donde estábamos de repente
se prendió una bengala precisamente a la
nos obligaba a llevarnos a tirarlo
cuerpo a tierra se apagaba la meca de la
corriendo lo más rápido de vuelta otra
bengala de otra vez cuerpo a día de
ratos tres veces así llegamos a un
arroyo decomisar gente hay un puente de
piedra ni a metros me sentiría si
cruzamos por el puente de piedra tira
una bomba en matar a todos juntos hay
que cruzar por donde venimos nos metemos
en el agua el agua hasta los hombros
salió del arroyo chorreando agua porque
la rodilla por ser así
eso los demás
cansado tengo hambre por frío tengo
miedo que quiera combatir hasta que sí
vino mi compañero mi 90 compañeros
iguales hay más fuerza y más ganas hasta
que llegamos
y aparece otro líder teniente primero
víctor hugo rodríguez ha logrado un poco
carrera más viva la patria empezó a
correr de las bombas de la niebla y el
humo veo que sube el suelo
en un segundo y cuarto de ocre 1090
compañeros de la compañía corríamos
detrás en el jefe del grupo del sargento
villegas del cabo familia en su
expediente aristegui es teniente
rodríguez del cabo primero señor y esos
eran otros líderes
enseñaba lo que era y la combativa
y darle sentido a nuestras pertenencias
no había futuro teníamos que estar aquí
no corría por el otro y vamos codo a
codo con los compañeros llegamos hasta
la altura se veían sombra correr
disparamos nos disparamos nos quedamos
agazapado vemos qué va a pasar
el cabo fariña negrita bella sea posible
que los ingleses están corriendo y
llámese tries pasa la voz que vamos a
saltar cuando saltamos hacemos tres
pasos para delante una lluvia de balas
de 30 metros a la redonda nos obliga a
tirar más de cabeza del piso apoyamos la
cara contra la tierra esas balas pasaban
por arriba nuestro
escucho tries estoy herido me comí
izquierda lo veo el soldado ruso
tengo un tiro del brazo 300.000 hago
torniquete lo que esté acá después te
saco me arrastro disposición lo vi ver
sargento que estaba ahí tirado adelante
el sargento hemos sostenido mi sello
también que tiene
tengo un tiro la falsa
existir están saliendo las balas se nos
veía el relleno de la paleta de color
rojo que venían hacia adelante con dos
puntos de comenzar juntos que estar en
medio corre hacer y sentir el igual
podemos apuntar digo mi sargento que
estar en medio no le puedo tirar con
láser y sentir el igual que el fas
felicidad
ya no tenía futuro
pero mis agentes sistemas es corre no le
tiró me se teje que le tiró yo y así
como estaba colaba boca abajo estira el
brazo para agarrar el fusil cuando lo
está narrando le pegaron un tiro a la
mano
el sargento se da vueltas a sacar
correas de sacar las granadas no mucha
gente lo vamos a buscar que desee y
nadie se deban de espera en órdenes y
cuando levantó la cabeza a miles y miles
de bolitas de fósforo prendido estaban
cayendo arriba nuestro yo nos estamos
quemando vivos otros
al lado mío estaba el sonrojo seguir
cerezuela
en el mes de marzo dentro del servicio
militar y en el mes de abril estaban al
verla
un mes
como amigo
vamos a jugar a villegas alto que
necesitábamos
a la cruz aún por salir con el fusil
leído de helmuth y la cata díaz no van a
ser bolsas y baja el fusil ak apoyando
el fusil levantamos los brazos caminamos
los 78 pasos lo agarramos al sargento lo
arrastramos a trabajo la piedra que
salía mucha sangre
no había cura había morfina estamos a
ocho kilómetros de hospital
contarle a mi mamá
a mi mujer a mis hermanas
como vea que yo me quedé en el campo de
batalla
y el sueño de él era ver a su hijita
silvana de 3 añitos de la abraza reír y
abrazarse cuando volviese cuando veía
que se sueño no iba por cumplir
se puso a llorar
es un padrenuestro
esto es una brazada arriba la panza no
aguanto más este dolor pegamos un tiro y
hacete carrera
mucha gente tenemos lo que me ha salvado
he casado un hablas yo esté liquidado
yo me hago cargo del grupo los berros
seres sobre jolie pitt canta uno de los
diez soldados que quedan en uno por uno
avísale que hay que bajar no hay más
nada que hacer ya está
el sargento me pedía que él no lo toca
sino que debería estar a él me lo
agarramos con otro soldado y en vez de
bajar como subimos bajamos en el campo
de batalla de gritándole mis amigos que
no nos disparamos que lo llevamos al
sargento herido
caminamos 8 km llegamos al hospital
la maravilla de otros médicos con muy
poquitos salvaron cientos de vidas entre
ellas
y las
el regimiento 3 infantería entre los 5
que es la patria
el soldado andrew holmes
el soldado josé antonio reyes lobos
soldado julio segura
es oscar soria
el soldado maestro julio rubén ko
maestro está sagrado de la escuela
número 32
que cuando la patria llamó la ley la
madre y el jefe de compañía le hicieron
cabo gracias por venir pero usted no
tiene que ir a ningún lado usted está
casado es mujer está embarazada no tiene
nada que hacer y se le plantó a ellos y
les dijo ustedes le parece que yo me
paré frente a mis alumnos y les hablé
la belleza y lo grandioso y lógico de
nuestros próceres en general san martín
de belgrano de güemes y cuando la patria
me llama su maestro sepáis cuando debajo
de la cama
y julio nunca lo fue
cuyo miedo de la guerra
le quería una carta a sus alumnos
a mí queridos alumnos hasta sagrado t
su maestro está montando guardias
malvinas en nuestras islas malvinas
y cuando yo regrese
como un sueño en vuelo de cóndor
vamos a vivir juntos y te voy a contar
lo hermoso que son otras
nos quiere mucho firmado en junio
el 14 de junio a las 9 de la mañana
no pudo tener el futuro
pero si cumplir ese sueño
porque esa carta está en todas las
escuelas de nuestro país cada docente
seguía con esa carta
por eso le digo
no dejemos de vivir el aquí y el ahora y
cada instante disfrutar esta charla
disfrutar este día abrazarnos con los
que tenemos al lado volver a decir te
quiero
gracias saber pedir perdón
nos hace grandes
y el perdón
separemos tanto tiempo pensando en el
futuro y dejamos de vivir hoy
conoció la guerra y tardé muchos años en
entenderlo y poder asimilar de
compartirlo
por eso
en la bolsa que les dieron a cada uno de
ustedes van a encontrar
yo lo llamo esta vida
que hice hoy es siempre argentinas
que simboliza esto
que cada uno de nosotros lleva una
madrina hacia arriba
puede ser una enfermedad terminal un
accidente la pérdida de un ser querido
esto que nos tiene que dar la fuerza
para decir
y volver a dar ese paso adelante salir
de la trinchera y enfrentar a la vida
sale de nuestro corazón
[Aplausos]
[Música]
cantando web